[Music]
it may not mean nothing to y'all but
understand nothing was done for me so I
don't plan on stopping it
all my CL is whever my ever my Ever
Getting hits bigger than
all Big T just can't keep up with me I
just love watching him
fall no Club is forever my hey hey got
my club in the building ain't no
question who about to trigger only have
good streams big Fame big names I get
more clicks in one night than in your
week's game we go hard no fall like your
R tangs CNN plus didn't even make it
through spring we've all seen your story
no glory quom groping in turns you could
call it statuto when my knee blew up
didn't stop nothing for me old man new
dad Crowder what nothing it's super sad
you two give me no love in you would
think I had traps like for Rock's
husband why they always got to screw me
when they really doesn't got that noty
Bell working no it fing doesn't we led
by suching losers m g to kick you in
your ass pooper trade the subx just to
get the moment back remember we had the
lips rabbit like a dog pack follow the
tards it'll turn you to a maniac forget
Hollywood they can't even act
pull the wrong pronouns out how damn
they snap been working for this forever
try to pry it
back it may not mean nothing to y'all
but understand nothing was done for me
so I don't plan on stopping it
all M Club is whereever Ever Ever
Getting hits bigger than
all big Tech just can't keep up with me
I just love watching and
fall my for mind
mind
okay hello it's the cobbert no jokes
clapter never ending crap like a bow at
Olive Garden laughters not the target
appeasing violent markets like steel
with the pecker when he sees it got a
scar Kimel never stops crying like a
tiny to living in his gated Mansion Bing
about the cops so many crocodile tears
bit he needs a mop but what did he cry
for painted his face door my mind's fine
even when the time seem dark W on my
side you don't want to hear that thing
talk let the king talk stream and Rumble
go and click it now we got a whole team
so we all can kick it it's life Texas in
the middle of the summer it's hotter
than in Hell left this needs a must
umbrella don't waake the sleeping Giants
election season about to be your
mothering
blood may not mean yall but understand
nothing was done for me so I don't plan
on stopping at all
my club is forever ever ever getting
hits bigger than
all big Tech just can't keep up with me
I just love watching and
fall no Club is forever mind never mind
never
mind there they go p in theaters as we
come to spit the jokes nuts they go
triggering leftist anyone know what a
score some C some col it blow a
colan n a cut huh hey I'm I'm going to
let you finish
but N I can't let him finish we got come
[Music]
h